cuidar de todos é um prazer estar aqui
para vos falar num processo criativo um
pouco diferente em todos os processos
criativos neste caso dos doentes
como é que muitas vezes os doentes e
nova estava registrado como é que o
nosso projecto de investigação
nós não só estudamos o processo criativo
das pessoas a perceber como é que surgem
produtos e serviços com grande em três
como é que criamos uma plataforma que em
cerca de três anos se tornou um grande
portfólio de tecnologia médica não
apenas de idéias mas também de produtos
e tecnologias
deco diz estas criadas por doentes cerca
de 700 vidas literalmente todo mundo que
aliás tem ganho nos prémios para ter uma
ideia o senhor ban ki-moon anterior
secretário geral das nações unidas
aconteceu-nos em dezembro e 2016 estamos
a contribuir para os objetivos para o
desenvolvimento sustentável ao mesmo
tempo fomos considerados no processo
está a fazer tv dizer que tudo isso
acontecer um pouco por acaso
deixem me dizer exatamente o que eu
estou a falar e deixem falar do senhor
até alguns vôos entrem na fotografia
o engenheiro inglês em 2002 foi homérico
eo médico disse uma coisa que eu não
estou a ver que era que eu ia morrer e
morrer porque a horta da horta deu é não
era suficientemente robusta para todo o
fluxo sanguíneo por lá passava então
médico explicou que o que antecipava que
você acontecer é que veria uma ruptura
na aorta
certamente eles não conseguiram conter e
que isso certamente causaria a morte e
índice bux de acontecer nos próximos
dois anos
o hotel ficado chateado com as notícias
como devem calcular eu não queria morrer
e fui para casa a pensar que era um
pouco ridículo que dissessem que eu ia
morrer porque eu tenho um tubo por
cássia horta em que ter uma cultura ea
pessoa quer dizer nós em casa quando
temos um tubo que vai ter uma cultura
fazendo o pac 2 porque não haja uma
cultura somos um dia volta a qualquer
coisa não é a ordem que mais me
encaminhou documento que tem de fazer
mas ainda assim em casa e alcançou
considerou que vem além da fotografia um
device que alguns meses depois ouviu o
médico para o cara
volta da ordem devem calcular que não é
o mais comum na inovação ensina quando
um doente entra pelo gabinete do médico
dizer acho por meter me estava a ordem
não é eu sei que pode correr mal e seu
mérito e nesse caso eu corro risco de
vida e posso morrer
aliás foi com eles que acontecer
qualquer maneira resumida a história não
convenceu em inglaterra o médico é com
carne que o suporta ordem
ainda bem que o fez é o seu em 2004 e há
cerca de duas semanas não tem alguns
morte por sinal a dizer pelo estou muito
feliz porque ontem em londres no
paciente números saem possível o suporte
a ordem que eu desenvolvi para mim
próprio
isso é um pouco estranho não é não é
isto que normalmente esperamos ouvir uma
palestra sobre inovação na saúde
aliás depois hotel ou se encontrarmos o
árbitro foi desleal que após com o
acidente ficou tetraplégica na rodada
eu não acho nada por baixo do pescoço e
foi o árbitro foi que desenvolveu o
ex-cliente mais sofisticado que existe
no mercado
aliás hoje é um brinquedo chamado de
assento custa cerca de 85 mil dólares
depois descobrimos mais chances da
inglaterra um caso completamente
diferente
o michael é ter um técnico é tamanho 1 é
doente crónico e basicamente 325 a
pressões
uma parte dos deficientes foram
removidas e eu aqui vou eu de otimizar o
que significa que abriram um buraco aqui
na parede é por onde hoje escola em
todos os conteúdos adicionais para um
saco
é como eu lixo uma grande que eu queria
como devem calcular
na verdade existem 5 milhões de pessoas
neste planeta que não consegue ver este
é um dos problemas deste sábado como já
diria que é uma grande e queria eu nunca
traí a sensibilidade de perceber se o
saco tá cheio tamanho está vazio e por
essa razão o michael desenvolveu o que
venham e basicamente um súa um sensor se
aplica é esse sax e que permite
comunicar com o telemóvel mas caso o
iphone permitindo a queda estando
perceber se sabe está cheio tamayo está
vazio para mais uma vez um doente e não
apenas 9 o seu problema mas acabou por
resolver o problema
muitos outros doentes à volta deste
planeta e nunca mais acabavam os
exemplos de jogos de simples contato 700
histórias destas não vou contar
certamente como no caso do implante o
luís tem uma história diferente
o ie é um paciente com fibrose cística
fibrose cística é uma doença complexa um
dos problemas da fibrose que este que é
que estes doentes precisam limpar os
pulmões
se não limparem acabam por ter
impressões pulmonares e podem morrer por
aí é uma doença fatal mas felizmente a
esperança de vida aumentou de cerca de
45 anos para cerca de 40 o que nós
tivemos é que muitas das funções que
funcionam por esta doença foram
desenvolvidas por doente como esta
solução desenvolvida público antes o
lyon e foi um concerto eo possível mesmo
com certo é que estava a acontecer há um
estranho primeira horas postar em
silêncio e percebeu que eu tinha crises
toss quando os músicos tocavam e quando
os músicos passavam de carro à prova de
ser e quando os músicos tocavam cia e
foi aliás muito embaraçoso porque eu era
só encostar em silêncio e diz as coisas
começaram a mudar o olhar estranho né
o intervalo foi muito embaraçoso
espanhol também porque eu estava super
confortável influência e as pessoas
olhavam pra eu porque o time estava
decidido na primeira parte e ele assumiu
em tribunal será a oportunidade do prius
itub bcba mas eu não tenho e tosse
na segunda parte foi ainda pior porque o
andamento da música aumentou e o clue
teve que sair do concerto e foi para
casa apesar daquilo por que que a música
tinha criado uma crise de hipertensão o
terceiro com certeza a explosão e
percebeu que estava a acontecer porque
eu estava sentado à frente dos
altifalantes e basicamente estava alvar
com todas as vibrações musicais que
vibravam os pulmões causando todos aqui
o desconforto
resumindo a história o doe percebeu que
era a vibração que o podia ajudar a
limpar os pulmões e em casa como e logo
seguiram concertos dias começou a
experimentar com alto falantes me deu só
devo lançar à frente dos pulmões e por
si funcionava havia música que
funcionava melhor do que outras 117 8
que era a melhor maneira de limpar os
pulmões
eu fiz várias experiências e percebeu
que o ideal seria mesmo tentar cortar a
música deixando apenas as vibrações
resumindo a história foi o i que
desenvolveu o frio é ser de má que ele
tem aqui que hoje é acusada por muitos
destes doentes que utilizam precisamente
quando aqui há algum tempo à frente é
nos pulmões
para nós nunca mais parámos encontrar
soluções para idosos que instiga e
muitas outras doenças é desde o uso de
trampolins o que o tribunal faça uma
criança vibra tudo é o vibrato sobretudo
meus pulmões ajudando depois é que o
doente neste caso a criança tem
especulação ou da vitae é que o davi não
é o doente quem é doente e filha o filho
da gente percebeu é que era muito duro e
muito difícil eu comecei a filha é fazer
o tratamento médico recomendado que é
uma coisa que se chama pepe significa
passar umas horas por dia é superar em
vão
e eu basicamente para convencer a filha
a fazer isso meu que eu era viciado em
jogos e aí o que o fez em vez de tentar
convencer a filha a superar em vão foi
na área e um objetivo e aqui agora e
filha através do que o device klink mil
têm à frente da boca controla o jogo de
computador porque ela é o supra
no fundo é que o equipamento permite
três formaram o o o sopro em sinais
eletrônicos fazendo dessa forma o
controlo do jogo e dessa forma também é
fazendo o tratamento que tem que fazer
então vê agora já estamos a trabalhar
num conjunto de frente de inovadores que
são os cuidadores
agora é o pai que desenvolveu algo pra
filha ou ainda desenvolve o paa algo
para o pai como os dois exemplos que vêm
aqui quando é que ele teve um cancro o
pai percebeu que ela tinha que passar
muitas horas por dia é errada já que o
suporte que existem nos hospitais
então pessoa que podia talvez tornar
menos dolorosa toda esta experiência
desenvolvendo uma mochila que permite a
miúda ter algum alguns graus de
liberdade enquanto faz o tratamento o
mais direito a solução da deb leve tem
uma criança com paralisia cerebral
quando este mil supostos comentários e
quem sabe mudar simplesmente não são
capazes de fazer
então a seven desenvolveu este
pepsi um sistema que é possível com um
mês que as crianças vestem e depois se
agarra o corpo do adulto e os pés no
duto móvel é que as crianças nem desta
maneira os primeiros passos ou então
caso da joaquina deixa é foi aliás muito
importante para o nosso projeto porque
juninho tem uma solução bastante simples
e quando vemos os laicos tivemos que se
trata de rotina tem uma criança com
síndrome da água é uma doença complexa
mas mais uma vez um dos problemas é que
estas crianças quando são expostas
levantar se começar a andar e não tem
motivação não tem massa muscular para o
fazer e simplesmente não se levantam já
podem dizer com o calendário
acho que ele tenha tentado praticamente
tudo socialistas internacionais dos
estados unidos em tal e nada por ser
funcionário ou um dia que ela foi a uma
festa anos e o que era pro é que viam os
bolões dell muitas cores a flutuar no ar
e pela grande surpresa dela quando
criança viu os bolões e flutuar ficou
toda a gente sabe nos balões e mais
incremento gonçalo com suor salte para
agarrar os grandes vilões enquanto
juntinho e viu que o gonçalves alguns
balões uma coisa tão fácil de arranjar
foi imediatamente as compras foi comprar
balões comprou muito longe cheio delas
foi para casa depois de os bolões por
casa toda e pouco tempo depois o gonçalo
andava para esta solução é tão simples
que basta olhar a fotografia também
surpresa e muitas destas palestras que
tem feito como tbm vai perceber que
ninguém conhecia e ele pessoas na
audiência que às vezes me escreviam
dizer obrigado compartilhar porque eu
tenho uma criança com a mesma doença
como doença diferente
conheço alguém e resulta não devia ser
preciso ver estes live e ouviram falar e
por isso nós percebemos que havia um
problema é ver um problema de difusão
realiza um problema conhecido na
inovação
estas funções não chegavam às pessoas
que elas precisavam e foi aí que nós
queremos criar esta plataforma
a princípio ia ser apenas um projeto de
investigação e depois decidimos deixá la
aberta e algum tempo depois percebemos
que tínhamos 50 mil doentes na
plataforma
temos um portfólio de 700 inovações e
quitou apenas a cantar aquelas que já
foram
rodas com a nossa equipe a minha liga
porque na realidade temos bastantes mais
que não foram aprovadas em média é por
vagas limitado daquelas que são
submetidas
em média estamos a receber cerca de 3 e
9 ações por dia
vamos aprovar uma ideia por dia em média
foi literalmente todo o mundo quando nós
tínhamos juntar à comissão europeia diz
que nós éramos o melhor do dia foi o de
metais na europa o maior portfólio
tecnologia médica na europa o que a
gente sente que nós não temos ninguém é
desenvolver tecnologia liga são os
doentes mas não as funções de
responsável ganhar alguns prêmios
interessantes desde logo o apoio das
sessões doentes literalmente em todo o
planeta na austrália e na malásia
nos estados unidos alguns pensamentos
muito importantes como das nações unidas
tinham venceu duas vezes é alguns
prêmios 27 como quando fomos o projecto
mais votado pela cravo em uma competição
organizada com árvores business club
palavra do médico em que participaram
475 projeto todo mundo ou quando é
conhecer o pai me chamou uma startup to
fall uma pequena empresa a seguir o que
é curioso porque nós nem sequer somos
uma startup é o quanto a gênero a
escrever um artigo muito elogioso dizer
muito bem na nossa plataforma e as
pessoas perguntam como é que vocês
conseguiram que nós não sabemos porque
simplesmente não fizemos nada porque
isso acontecesse
quando fomos um de 11 projetos assinados
por estar no ano 9 mensalmente uma semi
players mundiais em que o principal
suspeito era urbana e depois houve com
os projetos todo mundo
nós éramos o único na área de saúde ele
esteve em destaque quando o museu de
ciência do ano nos convidou para
participar numa exposição que será
realizada uma exposição sobre nós e é
literalmente sobre nós as pessoas fazem
parte do projeto e depois muitas das
nossas inovações e o quinto set nesta
exposição é que a água tenha dado
interessante por mais de vinte e nove
países ao longo de toda a europa é
porque ontem por quase que vai fazer
chegar o nosso projeto é muita gente e
se os doentes não sabem da nossa
existência e isso é nos ajuda é nojo dos
próprios doentes
esta é a nossa pequena equipe é parte da
equipa que é está em lisboa são pessoas
da minha área e pessoas que instigam a
inovação é é fazer inscrição nestas
áreas e postei uma equipa médica que ela
hidrata professora helena canal ou então
nossas mais elevadas
a demora no qual temos um enorme orgulho
uma vez que temos é vários prêmios nobel
hoje na nossa equipe temos dois é que
nesta fotografia
os prémios 3 a 3 em breve é basicamente
é isso tudo tem também sustentava um
conjunto e nem acreditava ou processos
novos e criativos
deixe me contar as histórias do senhor
iphone o iphone entre néstor garcía é um
papo tia ciata um produto é fácil para
pessoas mais honestas para o teatro
a certa altura o que o iphone fazia
estava produziram mãos falsas como
aquelas bem na fotografia
o que eu fiz a certa altura eu venho no
canto superior direito
foi uma mão gigante mexe e que o colocou
no youtube fez um vídeo da mancha e
colocou no youtube e quando eu pontuou
para quem surpreendeu
poucos minutos depois de um irmão de um
quer pintar na áfrica do sul também vê
na fotografia
o recheio do naça escreveu à ministra
ouça eu vi é mau que com forlán e simão
muito interessante parece o eduardo mãos
de tesoura mexe é uma mão que estava ter
só porque eu tinha cinco dedos de
máquina portão 3
eu não tenho dinheiro para uma própria
daquelas mais a sério custa 10 15 mil
vagas
você fez parece suficientemente barato
porque eu possa ter acesso isso não sabe
o que dizer
eu disse que sim e ajudou a ter uma
prótese
ao mesmo tempo conhecer o nosso projeto
e aí que eu começar a interagir na
plataforma com algumas pessoas como
carro aqui é meio do número em certa
altura a carla aparece no nosso projeto
vai ter a porta a dizer eu sei que vocês
têm uma impressora 3d será que vocês não
podem imprimir uma mão para o mono nas
linhas das mãos e um braço porque o nome
investidos em uma mão e sem um braço
nós também não sabemos bem o que dizer
que o que dissemos que sim
não fazemos a mínima idéia de como
iremos ajudar mas o irã já tinha
partilhado com o carro o código vai
permitir a produção desta mal e então
começamos no fim de semana é trabalhar
na produção do mal que devo dizer que
estou cerca de 18 euros a produzir 18
euros não os desks mil dólares mas no
fim de semana 11 sábado a equipe tem uma
conferência
sabíamos que teríamos é ajudar o nuno eu
estava nos mostrar um curtíssimo vídeo
em que vivemos como é que foi pedido
está um vídeo com muitas mudanças no
vento mais forte mas deixamos o tráfego
é que sair
arumar piu piu piu
disfarça bem nela ele peças fazem parte
do leque mais deu em nada seu irmão não
vai estar em campo é resultado de oito
biel civil mineira já estava fighter que
só faltava agora fazer todas as ligações
deve ser domingo hora do almoço
estamos aqui ninguém quer oferecer ao
governo
fio pesca não só tem 2 a série como
devem calcular
escolhemos uma temporada de pesca
conseguimos simular tendões domingo à
tarde chamamos onu
[Música]
logo murração médico esta é a primeira
vez que o número de roubo comum que
temos é é algo de vida
[Música]
esta é a reunião a nossa chief medical
officer são outras cores da equipa
ele porém nós costumamos dizer muitas
vezes que inovação é mas muitas
invenções de 30 virou hoje é que hoje a
inovação é bastante distribuída
muitas vezes não é preciso ser
especialista naquela área podemos fazer
contribuições muito impactantes ser um
com 18 e orós pessoas que não tinham
nada a ver com seu último movimento é
nossa equipe médica conseguiu dar uma
mão e um braço o nome
o investimento de um projeto que o
próprio criou para traduzir estas provas
têm já impresso mais 1200 prótese é
curtir esse momento mas quando falamos
de 1888
estamos a falar custos verdadeiramente
significativo para o bar em que o
movimento trazem para o doente
o que nós hoje estamos a fazer só queria
te dizer vos isto é tentar maximizar o
impacto das coisas que fazemos das
coisas que fizemos na verdade são feitas
por doentes pessoas têm em cidades e
portanto acabam por inovar para resolver
o seu problema e eu resolver o seu
problema muitas vezes resolvem o
problema
muitas outras pessoas eu estava muito
difícil alguma frase de um senhor que eu
não conhecia até que o seu próximo filme
no fim uma conferência parecida com esta
como diferencial disse era tudo é médica
e eu no fim desse qualquer coisa de
gênio você fez uma apresentação muito
gira mas é óbvio que não percebe nada de
medicina e eu tinha razão e e eu tinha
razão e não sei que eu dissesse aqui ou
daquela maneira como destaque em inglês
é é um pouco o governo deixa eu te acha
que é e eu é que sentou que é muito de
ajudar e eu quero dizer que eu estava a
pensar que eu acho que não preciso de
medicina só porque eu sou o general é e
continuou não é ele sabe que o dia
também trazer um amigo meu
alguns amigos meus pais para nos ajudar
e eu te confesso que eu olhei e pensei
estômago está desempregado e está à
procura do novo projeto e se criarmos
treinar algum desinteresse na conversa
quando eu vejo você agora está com a
cabeça noutro sítio
mas você vai pensar no que fazer depois
desse exame ajuda não deixem dizer o meu
nome é vício em drogas e ganhou o prêmio
nobel de medicina
e quando estava solar em alguns amigos
meus que eles podiam ajudar
estava a pensar nos outros prêmios nobel
da medicina que podíamos ajudar a trazer
alguma credibilidade ao seu projeto
você agora vai pensar nisso depois diga
que está em sala não deu imediatamente
disse
obrigado
[Aplausos]